[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya 75 ans hydro-québec voyait le jour
le 14 avril 1944 le gouvernement
d'adélard godbout nationalise la world
ait it and ports qui détient le monopole
de l'électricité sont l'île de montréal
avec cette nationalisation tous les
barrages et immeubles de cette
entreprise passe aux mains de la
nouvelle société d'état hydro-québec
mais les barrages autour de montréal
sont insuffisants pour répondre à la
demande du reste de la province
la société de la couronne se lance alors
dans la construction de nouvelles
centrales
elle s'aventure pour la première fois
sur la côte nord avec un premier barrage
bersimis elle creuse 12 kilomètres de
galeries dans le bouclier canadien et
construit ses premières lignes de
transport de haute tension à 315 kg vote
les barrages se multiplient sur la
rivière aux outardes et manicouagan
elle construira manic-5 le plus grand
barrage à vote multiple au monde
autre première les lignes de haute
tension passe à 735 kg volts
un exploit qui réduit le nombre de
pylônes sur le territoire
la jeune société double sa capacité de
production tous les dix à 1962 c'est la
deuxième vague de nationalisations
pilotée par le ministre des richesses
naturelles eau prenez les verts
hydro-québec consolide sa manie sur la
production et la distribution sur
l'ensemble du territoire et deviendra
pas fait même un des moteurs économiques
de la révolution tranquille en 1965
hydro québec se lance dans le nucléaire
avec la construction des centrales
gentilly 1 et 2 le nucléaire représente
alors 2 % de l'énergie consommée au
québec mais les coûts de réfection des
centrales mettront un terme à la filière
nucléaire en 1971 le premier ministre
robert bourassa danse le projet du
siècle pendant 25 ans en pleine taïga
annie km de montréal ont construit huit
immenses d'argent
ce qu'on appellera le projet de la baie
james devient un des plus puissants
complexe hydroélectrique du monde
en 1998 coup dur une tempête de verbiage
sans précédent j'ai une partie du réseau
de transport au sol hydro québec dépense
des millions pour rendre son réseau plus
robuste
hydro québec continue de développer son
réseau en plus des barrages elle se
tourne maintenant vers le solaire et
l'éolien
pendant 75 ans hydro québec est devenue
la société d'état qui génère le plus de
revenus dans le coffre de la provence